mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
a b is the diameter of a circle
a line zigzags between the diameter and
the circle
in such a way that it starts at point a
and ends at point b each of the angles
between the zigzag line and the diameter
has the same measure alpha the question
is what is alpha equal to i think luke
is from brazil for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
there are many ways to solve the problem
but i will use the inscribed angle
theorem
if an angle is inscribed in a circle and
has a measure equal to theta
then the arc it subtends will be equal
to two theta
we'll use this to solve the problem to
get started
we will first reflect the semicircle
about the diameter a b
next we'll label some of these equal
angles as alpha
label the remaining angle in this
triangle as beta
from here we're going to consider the
measure of the arc
bc we'll calculate it in two ways
first c a b is an inscribed angle of the
circle
with an angle equal to alpha therefore
bc will be equal to 2 alpha
we will calculate bc in one more way
notice we have two inscribed angles each
of which is equal to beta
so this arc will have a measure equal to
two beta
and this arc will have a measure equal
to two beta
therefore bc will have a measure that's
equal to four
beta we thus have bc
is equal to two alpha which is equal to
4 beta
which means that 2 alpha is equal to 4
beta
we'll divide both sides of this equation
by 4 to solve for beta
beta is equal to alpha over 2. now
we have a triangle where two of its
angles are equal to alpha
and one angle is equal to beta thus we
have two
alpha plus beta is equal to 180 degrees
we can substitute for beta and then we
can solve this equation for alpha
we get alpha multiplied by 5 over 2 is
equal to 180
we'll multiply both sides of the
equation by 2 over 5
and thus we have alpha is equal to 72
degrees
and that's our answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time
you